you know what the first thing we teach
our ninth graders
has nothing to do with football
all right hey heads up
summer's over
you know it's time to go to work has
everything to do with how to shake a
man's hand and have a lookie in the eye
and that's where we start
it has everything to do with building
great young men
and i believe if you do that the
football will take care of itself
my name is ron gladnick and i'm the head
football coach at torrey pines high
school
at hillsdale as a freshman i had the
benefit of
probably playing on one of the worst
football teams in the history of
hillsdale college
we were three and eight you know when
coach dye and coach lowery came to
hillsdale my sophomore year we spent the
next three months at six o'clock in the
morning
where they had turned the heat up in the
field house felt like 110
you know the most brutal workouts
quite frankly to get guys who weren't
committed to leave which a bunch of them
did and then over the next three years
i was a part of that transition from
being
you know a very bad football team to
being one of the best division two
football teams in the country
i was a business major and an english
minor
i love a liberal arts education for that
reason it creates well-rounded people
and like i tell everybody the most
valuable thing about hillsdale college
is you learn how to learn and as a
result of that i've always felt i don't
care what environment you put me in i am
going to learn
and then i'm going to become competent
and then i'm going to compete
my whole adult life i've been you know a
self-employed entrepreneur i've built
small companies into medium-sized
companies
and that entails being everything from
the ceo to the janitor and i would say
that very much
sums up my business experience my
football experience and my life
experience
2006
i brought everybody in a conference room
and said look you guys are brilliant i
hired all of you you're smarter than me
i'm gonna go coach high school football
you guys run the company and they did a
great job i always tell everybody i
worked hard my whole life to getting
back to doing what i love the most
when i first started coaching it was
like herding cats if you're if you want
to be competitive in
you know
high level california football
that it's it's 12 months of the year now
you know we we end our season we're in
the weight room the following monday
and a parent stood up and said why are
you doing this i said because it's hard
because boys need hard
because life is hard
my first season we were six and four in
18 we were
12 and
we've won the toughest league in the
county three times the expectations are
high
in march 2020 before our spring break
we were told school would be closed for
two weeks
it ended up being for over a year
i got more phone calls from kids in
trouble
from march of 2020 to
march of 2021
in all of my previous 14 years combined
we were right there
our kids after a lift i was looking at
the kids
and i i don't even know what came over
me but i looked at the kids i say look
i'm probably
going to crash and burn
but i promise you
i'm gonna do everything i can
as your head coach to get sports back
and that's how it started
local coaches parents and athletes say
enough is enough it's time for change
it's time to play sports again and now
they're holding an event to get the
state to pay attention head football
coach at torrey pines high school ron
gladden ron gladnick ron gladnick coach
thank you for once again joining us we
started we we formed six seal teams of
parent volunteers who had different jobs
i was in charge of seal team six
which was engaging our politicians we
started an app and we got 1600 head high
school football coaches in california in
the app and 7 000 assistant coaches
so 11 days after i started it was 4 30
in the afternoon my cell phone rang and
it was gavin newsom
talked
for 45 minutes and what i left him with
was this
i said governor we are not political we
do not want to be political we want to
do the right thing for kids
he wanted sports back but the
mosh pit of special interests that you
had to work through to get it back
from that day took five weeks until we
finally got it
done
and as a result not only did we get high
school football back we got all high
school sports back
all seasons were played from march to
june
youth sports were returned
it was incredible
three mil 3.3 million kids got to play
what could be better than that
at the end of the day our our whole
program here has nothing to do with
football
it has everything to do with building
great young men
and i believe if you do that the
football will take care of itself
and i learned that from dick lowry this
is stuff i learned from my college head
coach my defensive coordinator
so you know for me it all started there
[Music]